what do you think have you ever been
around people in hollywood were you like
that they're shady i don't want to be
around them
all the time like yeah all the time like
uh
people want something if you if you can
give if you can benefit
somebody else they want it you know i
like it
like unfortunately i can benefit a lot
of people in some ways so they
you just gotta it's it's about like
finding who's real
and who's not but that it's a weird
blurred line right there do you look at
young artists and i want to help that
person i think that person is great of
course
if i if i like the music if just or even
if i just like them as a person and i
can have them
you know develop their sound yeah i'm
i'm into that that's great do you take
them on the road or how do you do it
yeah we've uh we've taken people on
tours like shout out this
this girl artist named fem um super
super cool we took her on tour she's
killing it now
um on her own uh who else are we like
taking we're taking like
steve my homie steve but it's just crazy
because like uh
we've been around like other successful
people before they were successful
right like like little mosey shout out
to lil mosby he's killing it right now
doing so good
um we were i think we might have been
one of the the first people to like how
many
and there's a serious question how many
littles are there there's like a lot
it's like a huge thing now it's a little
emotional yeah i think it's always been
yeah it's always been a thing it's
probably bigger now than it is
and that was a dude that you knew back
before he was yeah this was like seattle
yeah seattle like like three four two
three years ago and now he's just
killing it and i'm not saying we
did anything you know for his like
success i'm just saying
we've just been around like i was around
xxx and tasya and i stayed at an airbnb
i picked him up from the airport
uh way back in the day and it was just
so cool insanely talented dude oh man
yeah yeah so [ __ ] talented him and
ski mask um
and it just i think there's something
about i think all artists
like if you surround yourself i will
sometimes like
like i was around xxx when they were
just blowing up and i wasn't [ __ ] you
know what i mean
but i think that rubs off on people a
little bit yeah what i'm gonna be around
people that are doing what if you
surround yourself with like
successful talented good people
i think that's where everybody comes
from you know what i mean right and
i was lucky enough to be surround myself
what separates those dudes
there's a lot of guys that get into that
try to do it what separates those guys
do you think is it is it work ethic is
it just
like from uh unsuccessful yeah from the
people that judge don't figure out a way
to put it together
there's something this might sound crazy
but i think there's something just
really divine
about it because again speaking about x
there was just something insanely cool
he just
gave off this energy that i've never
even felt like before
uh same with like juice world like when
i was around juice world a couple of
times
it just gave off this great divine
energy that you
know you know they're gonna be
superstars and just
kill it and i feel like it sucks that
their lives you know were
taken so early yeah there's just
something so divine about
them as people so that people yeah yeah
a little peep and all those are mac
miller too
oh mac yes and that that'll did you know
mac well uh
we were i would say we were friends
maybe more queens as friends but we had
we had uh
hung out a a few times yeah um
like public settings and stuff he was so
cool man he was he's one of my favorite
artists
yeah do you think that like
addiction for some for whatever reason
like a lot of people that are
addicts or have that mentality end up
being
being great artists um
unfortunately i think it seems to always
kind of
steer that way where yeah i do think
that drugs can provide you
not like a specific drug just drugs in
general can provide you with like a
different look on life
it could help the music it could hurt
the music
but like i said you could you could find
that inspiration sober
i just think a lot of people sometimes
get in this habit of thinking that they
can't be creative
without drugs or some sort of stimulant